mais d'abord donc l'entrée en campagne
du président candidat emmanuel macron
avec jérôme ramier c'est la fin d'un
suspense qui n'en était pas un emmanuel
macron et bien candidat à un deuxième
mandat le président de la république
descend dans l'arène de la campagne mais
au vu des circonstances l'elysée a
retenu une forme sobre une lettre aux
français publiée dans les journaux de la
presse quotidienne régionale
un choix presque imposé c'est le
candidat qui s'exprime le président lui
s'exprime à la télévision pour délivrer
des messages a su rendre sur des
situations extrêmement grave l'aco vide
le cren le candidat lui et
crise en ukraine oblige l'entrée en
campagne sera sans doute allégé
difficile d'imaginer rapidement de
grands meetings ou de déplacement
thématisé pour celui qui reste chef des
armées mais déjà dans son allocution
d'hier sur l'ukraine le président
désormais candidat s'est placé dans la
position du protecteur des français face
à ses conséquences économiques et
sociales
je n'ai et n'aurait qu'une boussole vous
protéger cette campagne permettra un
débat démocratique
important pour la nation mais qui ne
nous empêchera pas de nous réunir sur
l'essentiel la guerre en ukraine et ses
conséquences pour la france risque
d'accaparer une partie de la campagne et
si le président gère les affaires
diplomatiques
il a chargé le premier ministre de
construire un plan de résilience à cette
crise le mandat vous l'avez encore
entendu hier soir que m'a confié le plan
d'appui qui l'a confié au gouvernement
c'est de protéger nos concitoyens et
l'économie française des orientations
qui seront forcément commentée par les
différents candidats à la présidentielle
dans une campagne très particulière pour
laquelle il reste 37 jours avant le
premier tour de scrutin
l'entrée en campagne de même accro c'est
donc notre tout premier débat je vous
présente mes invités joséphine staron
bonsoir est docteur en philosophie
directrice des études et des relations
internationales du cercle de réflexion
sinopia jérôme sainte-marie ont soir
sondeurs politologues président de
l'institut pôle inbox olivier dorgan
bonsoir avocat au cabinet ashurst et
spectre expert en sanctions économiques
les ti sa culpabilité à disposition soir
laetitia et puis avec nous en duplex en
visioconférence benjamin morel qui est
maître de conférences en droit public à
l'université paris ii panthéon assas je
commence avec vous jallet morel puisque
vous avez une vingtaine de minutes à
l'eau à nous consacrer merci de d'être
là cette lettre à la pqr c'était quoi
tout simplement le dernier choix
possible si on faisait la liste des
entrées des formes d'entrer en campagne
mâcon qui avouent jouer avec le
calendrier il avait en effet plutôt
intérêt à jouer que ce calendrier parce
qu'une entrée en campagne trop tôt
aurait pu être potentiellement
problématique en obligeant à distiller
un programme qui pourrait être clivant
dans son électorat il garde un électorat
socialement très homogène mais qui sur
certains aspects peut malgré tout est
bien arrivé chez l'un de ses rivaux on
voit que notamment dans un sondage ipsos
ya une vraie porosité avec le vôtre
pécresse et puis de l'autre côté cette
rentrée tardive en campagne lui
permettait est bien de parier sur un
effet ralliement sous drapeau avec la
crise colis depuis en plus avec la
présidence française de l'union
européenne dont on ne savait pas qu'elle
prendrait évidemment à cette époque
cette tournure là donc on a un emmanuel
macron qui a repoussé l'échéance et qui
se retrouve aujourd'hui au pied du mur
avec qui plus est cette crise
internationale qui l'empêchent de se
déclarer dans des canons habituels la
déclaration à la pqr qui permet à la
fois de montrer qu'il est proche des
français et que en même temps et bien il
ne descend pas tout à fait dans la raid
parce qu'on est sur un format écrit la
vidéo également qui me permet de garder
une forme de distance c'est pas
forcément l'idéal pour se déclarer mais
au vu des circonstances chirac c'est
tout ce qui reste est la
vidéo a priori vérifier laetitia avec
l'elysée il y en a pas mais a priori on
n'a pas mon vrai avec emmanuel macron on
est toujours surpris puisque il est le
seul à posséder les mystères et les 1
200 points comme bon on verra bien en
tout cas la lettre c'est une certitude
joséphine staron la posture du président
protecteur qu'on a entendu hier soir
lors de son allocution qui était presque
déjà une entrée en campagne on la
retrouve dans cette danse est laid via
pas y'a pas de surprise ça va être l'un
de ses axes de campagne évidemment fort
c'est presque par l'actualité oui on va
dire qu'il n'a pas trop le choix non
plus on est dans une situation inédite
il doit à la fois être le chef d'état
celui qui protège les citoyens français
et en même temps il doit se déclarer
candidat avant la date limite qui est
demain là dessus c'est une stratégie qui
l'a peut-être réfléchi mais qui aussi
forcément bousculé par les événements
récents ce qui est intéressant avec
cette posture de protecteur sait qu
emmanuel macron se l'est appropriée sur
tous les sujets européens depuis de
nombreuses années déjà depuis le
discours de la sorbonne en 2017 emmanuel
macron diffuse cette idée d'une europe
protectrice une europe souveraine une
europe puissance et aujourd'hui ce qu'il
nous dit hier soir finalement dans son
allocution c'est que nous sommes prêts
la crise du crédit n aura eu peut-être
au moins ça de bénéfique c'est de
pousser les européens à adopter cette
europe puissance souveraine stratégiques
alors maintenant à voir comment cela
sera décliné dans les mois qui viennent
effectivement jérôme sainte-marie
l'europe jusqu'à présent c'était plutôt
un retour soir pour une large partie de
l'opinion française donc c'est bon
effectivement un retournement le voit
dans un baromètre doxa aujourd'hui qui
montre que 63% des français estiment que
l'union s'est montré à la hauteur de la
situation c'était une proportion inverse
est intéressant de comparer le jugement
sur lac sur la crise sanitaire est ce
qu'on peut pour autant parler d'un
retournement de l'opinion sur l'europe
qui pourrait donc profiter par ricochet
emmanuel macron alors pour l'effet
immédiat c'est certain qu'on est là
quelque chose qui où les gens se disent
de nouveau l'union fait la force c'est
formidable de réagir en tant
qu'européens sans se rendre compte en
réalité que tout cela se fait dans le
cadre d'une alliance militaire l'otan
qui n'était pas une alliance européenne
qui est une alliance ou direction
américaine vont à raconter d'histoires
et donc vous avez effectivement cela ça
permet d'éviter toutes sortes de sujets
j'aime la moldavie venez de faire de
faire une demande d'adhésion la géorgie
l'union européenne la géorgie donc
l'ukraine est évidemment quand vous
parlez en termes de sécurité tout cela
c'est tout à fait dans les circonstances
pareilles c'est formidable alors que si
vous commencez à devoir débattre sur les
conséquences économiques et surtout
social de l'intégration de pays comme
l'ukraine c'est à dire que toutes les
perspectives d'europe sociale prennent
un ton très différent s'il est une
moyenne entre le smic des pays
occidentaux et le smic aussi de l'équipe
heures du smic dans des régions comme
cela c'est dans six états dbsa c'est un
débat de temps de paix aujourd'hui même
le simple fait de dire ce que je suis
enceinte ni retrait par est monstrueux
pareil et c'est en fait bon faut voilà
c'est mais en réalité donc ça permet de
faire passer si vous voulez cette notion
d'europe d'un contexte dramatiser pour
peut-être autre chose que ce qu'elle est
véritablement sa provoc pour l'instant
un effet d'adhésion de l'opinion mais
dans des circonstances on en n'est pas
notre première au premier conflit
extérieur on a eu le temps d'étudier les
effets de cela sur l'opinion juste pas
petite histoire j'étais militaire à
matignon lors de la guerre du golfe en
chat dans le département des études
d'opinion donnant six mois j'ai eu tout
le loisir de voir les effets de cela et
je parle cet exemple là pourquoi parce
que françois mitterrand devient très
populaire en février mars est donc de 7
ans fin janvier février marque de 7,91
la même manière que jacques chirac lui
en s'opposant à la guerre en irak eh
bien ce sera très populaire en mars 2003
et dans les deux cas ça ne résiste pas
deux semaines au retour de la paix oui
ça ne dure pas mais la question là qui
nous occupe c'est quand est ce que la la
paix sera revenu peut-être pas d'ici au
10 avril environ on verra bien je ne
voudrais pas être un oiseau de mauvaise
augure olivier d'orgon emmanuel macron
là un peu évoqué aussi pouvoir utiliser
le le costume de présidant l'union
européenne puisque puisque il ya cette
présidence tournante on l'a vu notamment
avec l' annonce de ce sommet de la
défense européenne qui tiendra à
versailles les 10 et 11 mars prochain
donc la semaine prochaine en fait très
clairement emmanuel macron c'est
effectivement positionner sur une en
tant qu' effectivement président de
l'union européenne en tout cas pour pour
les six prochains mois ce qui était
absolument pas du tout anticipé il ya
encore quelques semaines et cette
présidence d'ailleurs faisait beaucoup
polémique parce que elle venait en plein
conflit avec la campagne présidentielle
française est d'ailleurs certains
candidats cités même prononcé pour une
record de cette présidence pour éviter
justement au chef de l'état de de devoir
avoir ce double costume de président de
la république française de président de
cette présidence tournante est également
candidat à sa propre réélection ce qui
est assez intéressant sur le plan
européen c'est que on a si c'est quand
même d'un point de vue juridique 1 et
j'en reviens messieurs j'ai
naturellement il ya un vrai mouvement
très fédéraliste ces derniers jours qui
est assez inhabituel il faut comme le
soulignait européenne qui est quand même
une administrativement et juridiquement
très lente dans sa prise de décision a
n'a jamais été aussi rapide et donc je
pense que très clairement emmanuel
macron s'inscrit effectivement dans
cette dynamique là d'où cette
convocation effectivement de ce sommet
les 10 et 11 mars prochains avec
également aux messages pense qu'on va y
revenir un petit peu plus longuement
tout à l'heure le point économique qu'il
avait déjà anticipé dès lors de sa toute
première prise de parole le le jour de
l'invasion de l'ukraine le 1er jour de
l'invasion d'ukraine en dix ans et en
prenant les français que cette guerre
s'inscrirait dans une durée et qu'elle
aurait des conséquences sur le quotidien
des français ce qu'il a l'air répéter le
premier jour du salon de l'agriculture
et lyon le samedi ma vie c'était samedi
quand il est venu pour 2 euros au salon
laetitia on va faire un focus avec vous
sur cette forme d'entrer en campagne
alors il ya un précédent on en a
beaucoup parlé depuis le début de de
cette journée pour faire aussi dans
cette émission forcément sémites héros
88 vous savez quoi toi je pense qu on en
a beaucoup parlé mais que ça arrange
l'elysée parce qu'il savait très bien
que en faisant en faisant cette lettre
aux français évidemment la référence à
françois mitterrand sautera aux yeux des
journalistes et que évidemment toute la
journée on répèterai alala emmanuel
macron s'inspire de françois mitterrand
mais je vais vous donner un scoop c'est
vrai voilà donc s'arranger disent ils on
l'aura bien compris françois mitterrand
il avait écrit cette lettre à la fin de
la campagne alors que il s'était dit
candidat le 22 mars je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez dans une archive qui a
était repassé aussi de nombreuses fois
face à henri sannier où il avait dit oui
voilà un petit oui qui suffisait à le
faire entrer - souris entre l'autre non
certainement un peu plus jupitérien et
il avait écrit cette lettre à tous les
français le 7 avril 1988 47 pages
18 mille mots sept chapitres alors je ne
sais pas si emmanuel macron plus courts
et nicolas sarkozy on oublie on oublie
souvent mais il avait aussi écrit une
lettre à chemy chers compatriotes à tous
les français le 5 avril 2012 la rue mais
alors pour mitterrand et sarkozy ni
françois mitterrand à nicolas sarkozy
c'était postérieur plusieurs semaines
après leur entrée en campagne la la
c'est l'acte à vendre est en campagne
c'est la différence surprise de emmanuel
macron fallait bien qu'ils aient leur
donne une 1 et puis je vais vous dire
tout son plan com a été revu de a à z là
ces derniers jours parce que il avait
choisi vraiment de s'inspirer de
françois mitterrand c'est à dire que au
départ il devait arriver comme ça lors
d'un déplacement quelqu'un peut-être un
français devaient lui poser la question
mais serez vous candidat monsieur macron
et puis leur ai dit oui comme françois
mitterrand et ensuite il voulait
expliquer pourquoi pourquoi il était
candidat à sa réélection bon bah
finalement on a enlevé la première étape
il va écrire cette lettre aux français
il a fait cette adresse aux français de
toute façon hier soir donc il a pris la
parole et déjà une vidéo qui tourne et
ensuite on verra le service après vente
on sait juste que son meeting à
marseille et bien sûr et alors ce qui
est intéressant
benjamin morel c'est que cette campagne
cette campagne elle va elle va être
courte pour le président pour une raison
c'est à partir du 28 mars on rentre dans
le principe de l'égalité du temps de
parole dans les médias donc ça veut dire
que si une télévision propose 20 minutes
à emmanuel macron le 29 mars elle doit
proposer 20 minutes à nathalie artaud ou
nicolas dupont aignan c'est c'est quand
même campagne très courte de fait non
comment vous l'analysez ça on n'est pas
tout à fait sur un régime de l'égalité
on est sur un régime essentiellement de
l'équité au moins depuis la loi de 2016
donc malgré tout pas si on pourra à
partir du 28 mars entre dans l'égalité
là on attaque les qualités où on est
dans une forme d'équité c'est à dire que
vous ne donnez pas les mêmes temps de
parole malgré tout à l'ensemble des
candidats depuis la loi de 2016 on a eu
une modification en profondeur là dessus
donc oui il ya en effet des évolutions
mais fondamentalement vous avez de toute
façon une mise en visibilité du
président la république et plus fort
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas seulement la
parole qui est la vôtre c'est également
la manière dont votre parole va être
relayée et dont elle va être audible
donc c'est une campagne en effet
excessivement courte pour emmanuel
macron mais ça a été dit c'est à dire
que y'a déjà précédemment l'exemple de
françois mitterrand et par ailleurs eh
bien vous avez aujourd'hui déjà une
forme de cristallisation c'est à dire
que l'enjeu n'est pas le même selon les
candidats pour un candidat qui est peu
connu une campagne longue s'impose parce
qu'en réalité vous avez la nécessité
d'être justement audible visible en
revanche pour un candidat et quand vous
attendez quand vous êtes un président
sortant que vous êtes connu qui est déjà
connue qui est déjà marquant et qui est
déjà attendu est bien la longueur de la
campagne est plus une occasion de
prendre des coups donc là pour le coup
une campagne courte une campagne éclair
et bien à part plus crédible pour
emmanuel macron également parce que
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
l'électorat macro n'y en a une forme
d'homogénéité sociale il est d'accord
sur le bilan des manuels macron mais sur
les perspectives qui serait celle du
projet et pas forcément d'accord n'y a
pas forcément de vision commune on le
voit d'ailleurs dans les ralliements qui
peuvent être très très divers emmanuel
macron elle qui peuvent incarner des
choses différentes donc des moments où
vous rentrez dans la campagne avec un
projet vous prenez des risques de cliver
votre électorat par ailleurs cette
élection va se faire probablement au
premier tour à droite l'idée c'est
d'arriver à capter cet électorat centre
droit qui pourraient s'échapper de
l'escarcelle du maquereau nisme mais le
second tour lui va probablement se faire
à gauche parce que du second tour enfin
le second tour dépendra du report des
voix de gauche sur emmanuel macron il
faut que ce report soit évidemment un
report sur lui et pas sur l'autre
candidat et il faut que ce report soit
important parce que il y à une
potentielle abstention différentiel qui
peut être extrêmement importante au wac
actuellement et un électeur jadot sur
deux qui votent emmanuel macron second
tour un électeur mélenchon sur trois
donc il faut pouvoir parler à la gauche
il faut voir parler à la droite et pour
arriver à un consensus et mais il vaut
mieux parler d'ukraine vaut mieux parler
de la choroïde que de pouvoir d'achats
de sécurité ou d'immigration sans doute
pas pouvoir échapper au pouvoir d'achat
jérôme sainte-marie ça faisait réagir le
le le second tour se jouera à gauche oui
parce que je crois que cette lecture
gauche droite est quand même largement
obsolète et le succès meubles d'emmanuel
bakr ont aujourd'hui succès considérable
à dans les intentions de vote le sondage
qui vient de tomber à l'instant le
rolling ifop indique 28% au premier tour
pour emmanuel macron 28% ces quatre
points plus que donc il ya cinq ans et
ses 11 points de plus que celle qui
arrive en numéro 2 à 17 % marine le pen
donc on a effectivement cette unité delà
du maquereau nisme est très forte et les
gens qui le rejoignent pas tout à fait
d'accord et jean luc morel sont à peu
près d'accord sur tout c'est à dire que
ce soit monsieur raffarin ou monsieur
rebsamen par exemple et monsieur
chevènement aussi parce que chevènement
s'est rallié à tous qui tous qu'il tout
ce qu'on pouvait tout ce que bakr on
pourrait lui dire donc n'a plus aucune
forme d'importance politique donc vous
avez effectivement 7 cette convergence
soit un projet commun sur une culture
commune désormais très largement
européen n effectivement ça fait pas une
majorité mais face à eric zemmour ou
face à marine le pen ça fait une
majorité face à pécresse les mêmes
images rendues plus grande imaginez-vous
alors je votre réponse benjamin morel et
je pense que ce sera votre dernier mot
puisque vous devez filer juste après
désolé non mais alors sur les identités
politiques en effet je suis d'accord il
ya une forme de dissolution malgré tout
vous avez des intentions de vote
aujourd'hui qui sont relativement
stables notamment pour les candidats de
gauche et cet électorat il va être
nécessaire à emmanuel macron et pour
l'instant il est stable ensuite il ya
malgré tout des points qui font clivages
dans cet électorat c'est notamment quand
vous prenez les enquêtes la question de
l'immigration
l'électorat de son coup droit est très
opposée à une immigration plus
importante c'est moins le cas pour un
électorat centre gauche or sur quoi
emmanuel macron va devoir répondre à
eric zemmour à marine le pen et même à
valérie pécresse ce sont sur ces sujets
là s'il est trop mou sur ces sujets là
ils peuvent perdre électorat centre
droit s'il est trop dur et bien c'est
l'électorat de gauche qui disent que de
dire bonnet blanc blanc bonnet on voit
d'ailleurs que c'est un électorat qui se
fragilise dans son report de voix
emmanuel macron au moment de la loi zyl
et immigration puis au moment de la loi
anti-casseurs acceptera les grandes lois
sécuritaires et les lois sur
l'immigration ont touché cet électorat
et vont conduire peut dans l'évolution
des enquêtes a modifié le rapport le
report de voix donc là il ya un danger
pour emmanuel macron il en a assez bien
conscience nous le fait que sur ce sujet
là il parle assez peu directement dans
voit plutôt des lieutenants et par
ailleurs eh bien il évite de rentrer
trop tôt dans la campagne ce qui est de
bonne guerre merci benjamin morel pour
cette analyse effectivement il ya cette
question d'une campagne un peu en
surplomb qui serait dans la dans le
prolongement de la stratégie du
président la république depuis plusieurs
semaines
ça agace et ça questionne la stratégie
de ses opposants on écoute marine le pen
c'était hier au salon de l'agriculture
si le président de la république pas
stratégie essaye de passer au dessus des
réponses qu'il doit aux français sur ces
sujets je crois qu'il commet
une véritable erreur et qu'il est
déconnecté encore une fois de la tante
forte du peuple
juste âgée en écoutant benjamin morel
bon bah emmanuel macron aura répondre
dit il à valérie pécresse eric zemmour
et à marine le pen pour l'instant au
chef de l'état a refusé tous les débats
du premier tour donc est ce qu'il aura à
répondre si les journalistes lui posent
la question vous voyez ce que je veux
dire thomas si les journalistes ne lui
pose pas la question de façon répétitive
il peut très bien la contourner mais
joséphine stars ont cette question du
débat du du premier tour si emmanuel
macron hésitait déjà avant la guerre en
ukraine balle à la question se pose plus
du tout enfin il va pas aller participer
à un débat de premier tour alors que il
faut en même temps appelé hier poutine
puis zelensky oui ça l arrange bien
d'une certaine manière probablement même
si ça ne faisait peut-être pas partie de
la stratégie et au départ parce que les
évènements s'enchaînent aujourd'hui ce
que certain c'est qu'avec cette crise
cette guerre il faut le dire en ukraine
les gens les français les citoyens ont
peur sont inquiets et c'est légitime et
donc forcément dans une période aussi
critique on recherche la stabilité on
recherche la cohésion on recherche
finalement d'être rassurés et c'est dans
cette posture là que se place
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron c'est ce
qu'il fait depuis le départ lorsqu'il
lorsqu'ils commencent les négociations
diplomatiques avec d'admir poutine il ya
quelques semaines même si elle échoue
emmanuel macron le dit bien dans son
discours hier soir nous ne sommes pas en
guerre contre la russie donc là il
rassure une population française qui
entend parler de troisième guerre
mondiale depuis quelques jours c'est
même très anxiogène et ighil l'inquiète
pardon de vous interrompre aujourd'hui
en faisant passer le message qu'il est
pessimiste après parce qu'il l'a rappelé
ce matin pendant plus d'une heure une
aria relayeur kittin et des halles a su
à l'un de ses coups de téléphone il
informe les français
la voie diplomatique et compliquée qu'à
une durée que en tout cas sur la
question de l'ukraine les choses
semblent perdus que vladimir poutine
devrait aller jusqu'au bout et devrait
revendiquer la totalité de l'ukraine
donc là dessus le maniema grondin n'a
effectivement on n'est pas très
optimistes
en revanche ce qu'il dit ce qu'il laisse
transparaître du moins c'est que la voie
diplomatique pour protéger autres
citoyens on pense à la mode d'asile ont
pensé à la géorgie on pense surtout aux
pays de l'union européenne et aux pays
membres de l'otan est bien là il
s'adresse en français en disant je ne
coupe pas la voie diplomatique
parce que c'est la seule qui nous
permettra de garantir la paix une paix
que les gens ont viscéralement envie de
conserver ici en europe euros qu'est ce
qu'on va retenir de ce quinquennat
j'admire premier quinquennat non parce
que c'est pas joué qu'est-ce qu'on va
retenir de ce noeud ce quinquennat le
président décrit c'est sans doute ce qui
restera évident je pense que vous le dit
très justement ottomane le président des
crises un président qui après un nom de
pouvoir fait face la crise dg les jeunes
puis à une réforme des retraites qui est
excessivement compliqué et puis à la
crise de l'aco vide pendant presque deux
ans et on commençait tout juste à être
optimiste sur cette sortie de crise et
on arrive dans une crise géopolitique
majeur que l'europe n'a pas connu depuis
à minima la guerre de l'ex-yougoslavie
donc clairement un président qui a eu
finalement un peu plus d'un an pour
exercer pleinement sur ses projets sur
les réformes qu'il avait sur lesquels il
avait voulu être élu en 2007 jérôme
sainte-marie est ce que l'opinion peu
tenir rigueur à emmanuel macron dans ce
contexte particulier de ne pas descendre
dans l'arène non je ne crois pas eu des
sondages qui avait été fait avant la
crise du crédit yens avant la crise
ouverte qui montrait que les français
s'impatienter et donc ça commençait à
apparaître comme une habileté un peu
déloyale pour tout dire de ne pas
exposer son bilan de refuser de débattre
de son projet mais aujourd'hui les
choses sont complètement changé là
dessus il ya un sondage très
intéressante mais moi je ne parle que de
sondages mais donc qui est qui a été
fait par bbva les 23 et 24 février juste
avant la guerre qui montrait que 42% des
français et cette guerre si vous voulez
l arrivée un peu par surprise pour
l'opinion française un bon pense que ça
va s'arranger qui avait une énième crise
mais qu'au fond tout cela était sous
contrôle et le 23 et 24 février dont 42%
des français ont une bonne opinion du
président sortant enfin de manuel
barroso comme président de la république
42 % ces dix points de plus que nicolas
sarkozy à la même période de son mandat
s'il 21 de plus que comment dirais-je
françois hollande les 42 % ça serait si
le président la république n'avait eu
qu'une seule opposition ça serait assez
inquiétant pour lui mais avec ayant
trois quatre cinq oppositions possible
avec des reports de voix avec des
reports de voix justement au second tour
entre ces différentes qui seront sans
doute assez mauvais et bien c'était déjà
assez confortable avant la crise
aujourd'hui si vous voulez il ya cette
crise qui arrive là voudrais juste dire
à faire une petite distinction entre les
crises du quinquennat de ce point de vue
là il ya deux périodes très différentes
d'un quinquennat il ya les crise sociale
du début du quinquennat dont
fondamentalement le présent la
république est le co auteur puisque
c'est bien à sa politique ses réformes
ces taxes son style etc qui nourrissent
les mouvements sociaux dont le gilet
jaune mais qui vont plutôt l'affaiblir
si je vous entends tu te rendes qui
renforce le localité avec qui crée peu
un peu à bloc populaire c'était ma thèse
à l'époque mais cette thèse je la
croyais et je la crois encore valable
dans les conditions du moment mais
appartement où vous avez le covin
notamment vous avez l'arrêt des réformes
vous avez la distribution d'argent vous
est ce cette crise qui vit qu est
totalement exogènes et qu'en plus après
vous avez une crise on ne peut plus
exogène qui est celle de l'ukraine dont
personne de petite et rigueur dans son
inde dans sa survenue au président de la
république l'a évidemment on est une
transformation radicale et ces cris cela
bien entendu le renforce et d'ailleurs
c'est intéressant parce que ça permet de
de continuer dans la logique du quoi
qu'il en coûte sauf
laetitia avec une nuance et un nouveau
mot qui apparaît c'est le mot résignant
s'est pas vraiment nouveau alors je vais
vous contredire suis désolé moi il n'est
pas nouveau ce mot leur nid dans la
macro ni ni pour les chefs d'état avant
françois hollande l'a beaucoup utiliser
après les attentats de 2015 et c'est
vrai que emmanuel macron hier soir en
tout cas a choisi ce mot pour lancer le
plan de sauvetage social et économique
écoutez
face à ses conséquences économiques et
sociales
je n'ai et n'aurait qu'une boussole vous
protéger j'ai demandé aux premiers
ministres d'élaborer pour les prochains
jours un plan de résilience économique
et social pour répondre à toutes ces
difficultés
on l'a dit un sur ce plateau depuis le
début du débat on a parlé de protection
il le dit je vais vous protège et donc
il endosse le costume du pater familias
le père de famille et pourquoi ils
utilisent résilience parce que
résilience ça veut dire que les français
sauront dépasser seront surmonter les
traumatismes les épreuves grâce à lui
puisqu'il n'est protège et et donc il
fait confiance dans cette capacité de
résilience du peuple français et c'est
une résidence que l'on partage donc
c'est lui avec les français il ya
plusieurs comme sa signification à voir
dans ce mot résilience et vous avez
raison il l'a déjà utilisé une semaine
auparavant au salon de l'agriculture
emmanuel macron exactement dans les
mêmes termes et alors je vraiment si
vous avez le temps essayé d'aller
regarder ce qu'il avait dit face aux
agriculteurs c'est quasiment mot pour
mot ce qu'il a dit hier soir aux france
à qui on l écoute
ce ne sera pas sans conséquence sur
l'augmentation des coûts de l'énergie ce
ne sera pas sans conséquence sur
l'alimentation du bétail son couple être
même la capacité à fournir et donc nous
sommes en train de bâtir et le ministre
le fera dans les prochaines heures avec
vous un plan de résilience d'abord pour
sécuriser pour nos filières nos intrants
ensuite pour essayer au maximum de bâtir
des boucliers en termes de coûts voilà
donc on est exactement dans l'idée dit
hier soir et ce n'est pas du tout du
tout la première fois qu'il utilise ce
mot puisque pendant le qu'ovide mars
2020 rappelez-vous à mulhouse il fait ce
déplacement il dit nous sommes en guerre
et il utilise encore une fois ce mot
résilience écoute elle j'ai décidé sur
proposition de la ministre des armées et
du chef d'état major des armées de
lancer l'opération résilience
cette opération
distincte de l'opération sentinelle qui
continue de se concentrer sur la lutte
contre le terrorisme
quant à elle cette opération résilience
sera entièrement consacrée à l'aide et
au soutien aux populations ainsi qu'à
l'appui aux services publics pour faire
face à l'épidémie de covin 19 le
contexte aujourd'hui est totalement
différent mais l'objectif et les moyens
le quoi qu'il en coûte sont exactement
les mêmes seule petite nuance peut être
hier soir il a utilisé le futur dans son
allocution pour bien signifier qu' il y
aurait peut-être en tout cas
certainement selon lui un deuxième
mandat voilà il ce mot résilience est
celui que vous avez choisi justement
pour votre chronique qu'on propose sur
nos réseaux sociaux alors effectivement
là la démonstration c'est pas nouveau je
suis d'accord avec vous mais ce que je
voulais dire en fait et est ce que ce
soit intéressant est évident c'est que
il aurait pu choisir de de continuer
d'utiliser le quoi qu'il en coûte voyez
ce que ce que je veux dire mais surtout
ce qui est intéressant c'est que moi je
trouve que il ne va pas pouvoir faire
l'économie et il ne fait pas l'économie
de descendre dans l'arène du quotidien
des français c'est à dire le prix de la
baguette le prix de l'essence on a vu on
en discutait juste avant que l'émission
démarre il ya des records battus sur
5,5 matières premières en ce moment qui
sont historiques quoi ça effectivement
alors peut-être sur le quoi qu'il en
coûte points commenté sur ce point je
pense que le quoi qu'il en coûte à une
connotation très particulière pour une
partie de certains candidats à droite
donc je pense qu'il voulait aussi
démarqué besoin d'engager voulait sortir
de ce de ce mot qui a été utilisé
pendant près de près de 20,4 mans est
sûre sur effectivement les conséquences
intéressant parce que quand on regarde
vraiment la séquence des sept derniers
jours emmanuel macron anticipe que les
mesures que l'union européenne prendra
auront des conséquences sur l'économie
française et sur l'économie européenne
et qu'elles auront des conséquences sur
l'opinion publique aussi parce que vous
dit très justement elles vont venir
toucher également le prix des
hydrocarbures le prix du gaz le prix de
certaines matières premières et donc je
pense qu emmanuel manqueront anticipent
une potentielle mécontent de mon donc là
on revient éventuellement au crise
sociale du début du quinquennat et donc
dans cette posture en fait ils adressent
directement la question de l'économie et
en même temps il recadre si vous me le
permettez également le ministre de
l'économie et des finances qui c'était
un petit peu emballé lors de son
entretien / sur france inter le laser
sur france info par dont la veille au
soir et n'ont que là il rappelle que la
guerre aura des conséquences sur notre
économie mais que pour autant nous ne
sommes pas en guerre d'un point de vue
économique avec la russie les 5 records
que j'ai trouvé sur sur brut
c'était sur twitter c'est pétrole gaz
blé maïs et aluminium je voudrais
entendre votre expertise sur l'aluminium
qu'est ce qui est en train de se passer
alors l'aluminium c'est très intéressant
parce que l'aluminium a déjà connu une
crise du fait des sanctions économiques
alors ça a été un épisode qui a été
relativement isolé mais les états unis
en 2018 décidé d'imposer des sanctions
contre rue salk est le premier
producteur mondial d'aluminium ce qui a
eu des conséquences énormes sur
l'inflation et le couple de lignum est
ce que l'on sait c'est que les états
unis ce soir à priori ou dans la nuit
pour nous avons ré imposé des sanctions
contre orissa donc l'inflation dont vous
faisiez peut-être ma a des raisons de
continuer et peut-être pour ajouter sur
un autre point qui est très intéressant
c'est l'inflation en matière de
diplomatie la russie est un des plus
grands producteurs mondiaux lithium tout
comme l'ukraine les lithium est
absolument critique à la décarbonisation
de notre économie et on risque là aussi
de voir une inflation du prix du lithium
et donc du prix de la transformation
écologique alors effectivement emmanuel
macron anticipe sur ce qui pourrait être
un boulet pour cette courte campagne oui
mais il montre aussi que la solidarité
européenne un coup un prix mais que ce
prix il est prêt lui comme tous les
chefs d'état européens à l'assumer et à
le compenser on envoie une union
européenne depuis quelques jours qui se
met en branle si je puis dire pour
compenser les effets négatifs des
sanctions qu'elle a unanimement décidé
alors est-ce qu'elle y parviendra
jusqu'au bout probablement pas il y aura
des conséquences qu'on ne pourra pas
maîtriser mais en tout cas c'est effets
compensateurs il est présent dans
l'esprit des manades macway dans
l'esprit de tous les européens mais on
surf aussi si je puis dire sur la vague
de solidarité à l'égard des ukrainiens
de l'opinion publique en france et
ailleurs en europe qui pour un temps en
tout cas pourra justifier ses
conséquences négatives et notamment à la
hausse des prix mais ça ne pourra pas
durer très longtemps et donc c'est pour
ça qu'il ya un vrai danger
sur l'opinion publique à long terme ou à
moyen terme en matière de sanctions et
de leurs conséquences il ya quand même
une différence entre les différentes
opinions publiques si vous voulez par
rapport à ceux de ces sanctions quand
vous êtes un pays comme la france où le
débat a commencé d'ailleurs sur les
problèmes de désindustrialisation
ou quand même les chiffres
catastrophiques de la balance
commerciale on était un petit peu
médiatisé et malgré tout quand vous avez
effectivement en plus l'expérience de
sanction qu'on peut apparaître comme
pénalisante par rapport à différents
secteurs et bien là ça devient très
différent quand vous êtes à payer
optimistes comme l'allemagne si vous
voulez où tous les choses semblent aller
mieux en mieux y'a pas de problème là
inversement c'est des sanctions qui
seraient là ça peut être un débat je
pense qu'il aura le temps de deux des
d'émerger et d'émerger et de se
développer au cours des prochaines
semaines avoir écrit les présidentielles
mais le point des sanctions c'est que ça
pénalise lourdement beaucoup de milieux
d'affaires français quand beaucoup
investir en russie par exemple se
demande si on n'est pas en train de
sacrifier de nouveaux investissements
sans garantie c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire d'efficacité sur la
situation sur le terrain donc si vous
voulez un moment donné sauvegarder son
âme pour risque de ne pas passer pour
insuffisant pour beaucoup d'acteurs
économiques pour beaucoup de français
parce qu'il n'ya pas que la
préoccupation sociale et la
préoccupation du consommateur il ya
aussi une préoccupation très forte dans
l'électorat c'est la préoccupation du
contribuable on est à dire que le quoi
qu'il en coûte et critiqué aussi parce
que beaucoup de contribuables relatifs
morizet c'est quand même plutôt
l'électorat d'emmanuel macron qui plus
est est bien à ce 10 mai ça va durer
combien de temps ces trucs l'argent on
avait une préoccupation rappelez-vous
depuis plusieurs élections
présidentielles avec bayrou avec même
madame royal tout cela dans 2007 sur l'a
10 mm et l axe d'entrée en voilà de
retour en politique
dire ça comme ça de l'ancien premier
ministre avec horizon d'ici là il a
parlé de la dette ça a été vraiment
discours philippe on n'en parle plus en
plus il mobilise pas mais nous
sous-estimons pas l'immense inquiétude
et contribuer notamment des retraités de
ceux qui ont du patrimoine tout cela
qu'ils disent mais qu'est ce qui va nous
arriver on va sortir de tout cela et
pourtant il ya certainement un parce que
là les sanctions sont historiques les
sanctions décidées par l'europe n'est
pas seulement l'europe mais il ya on en
a encore sous le pied pardon d'être un
peu triviale mais mais c'est ce qu'on
peut dire alors il ya encore moyen de
durcir ses sanctions on a encore en
moyen ultime de durcir ses sanctions
mais ce moyen potentiellement viendrait
pour le coup de très fortement pénalisé
l'économie française l'économie
européenne et le consommateur c'est le
secteur d'énergie le shaker de l'énergie
pour l'instant été épargnée
volontairement on est encore au tout
début du mois de mars on est encore dans
une position on est très consommateur de
gaz de gaz russes notamment et donc on
ne pas souhaiter c'est d'ailleurs une
position européenne qui n'était pas
forcément partagé par des états unis et
le royaume uni tune venir sanctionner
les apports de gaz russe et c'est
d'ailleurs pour cette raison que les
banques qui ont été discutées hier matin
un nouveau mot qui n'existait pas dans
notre vocabulaire mais cette reprise de
la bourse à être pris donc on rappelle
rapidement ce qui swingue alors suisse
et un système de communication bancaire
et qui permet à des banques partout dans
le monde d'échanger entre elles et qui
permet de sécuriser les transactions et
une déjà bien faire toujours de la
pédagogie et est donc effectivement dans
le choix de l'union européenne il ya
plusieurs banques russes qui ont été
exclus du système mais pas toutes bien
j'ai dit celle qui ne sont pas exclues
du système ce n'est pas anodin ses
sbires banques et gazprombank ils sont
les deux banques auxquelles les
européens font des virements tous les
jours ou tous les mois pour payer le gaz
russe dont ils ont besoin et sur la
question du débat sur les sanctions je
trouve que le débat sur l'efficacité des
sanctions il a déjà il est déjà dans
l'opinion publique je trouve en tout cas
il est dans les milieux d'affaires ça
c'est de toute évidence on voit bercy
tient quasiment quotidiennement des
points presse avec et des points
également avec des plus grandes
entreprises françaises pour justement
anticipez vous disait très justement les
lourds investissements qui ont été faits
par de grands groupes industriels
et de grands groupes même dans le
secteur des services aux russes y donc
le débat il est déjà présent et je pense
que emmanuel macron l'avait déjà
anticipé surtout qu' il faut le rappeler
on est quand même dans un contexte où on
a choisi de faire de cet outil juridique
la réponse est l'unique réponse enfin on
a eu effectivement une solidarité
européenne en matière de défense mais on
a un à faire en tout cas la principale
réponse à cette crise est donc l'enjeu
c'est pour emmanuel macron c'est aussi
de ne pas de préserver cet outil de
faire en sorte que cet outil puisse
continuer à être utilisés et continue à
être crédible d'où l'importance
justement qu'il n'y ait pas un débat qui
viennent aussi contesté ces sanctions
merci les quoi aux entreprises vous
inquiétez pas vos investissements ne
seront pas perdus persie est beaucoup
plus prudent sur ce point très
clairement bercy
n'encourage clairement pas les
entreprises à poursuivre leur
massivement russie bercy est assez
pessimiste mais surtout bercy est assez
attentiste parce que la russie est en
train de préparer des contre mesures
notamment pour essayer d'interdire les
sorties de capitaux étrangers de son
territoire donc je pense que
malheureusement la messe est déjà dite
et que les investissements majeurs qui
ont été réalisés par des groupes
industriels en russie devront à minima
rester en russie le temps des sanctions
et potentiellement disparaît et on est
au coeur de notre débat sur ce sur cette
campagne à la forme que prendra cette
campagne présidentielle pour emmanuel
macron parce qu'évidemment ça va être
aussi un levier de communication pour
lui les routiers c'est l'une des infos
de cette fin d'après midi les routiers
demande d'ores et déjà l'aide de l'état
et on a bien compris on l'a entendu tout
à l'heure dans notre sujet d'ouverture
que c'est le rôle qui est dévolu au
gouvernement et au premier ministre 2 2
de mettre en musique la la résilience
puisqu'on ne dit plus quoi qu'il en
coûte je voudrais terminer ce premier
débat sur la question de la légitimité
d'un éventuel emmanuel macron réélu dans
une campagne
a minima et je voudrais entendre ce que
disait ce que nous disait gérard larcher
c'était hier dans notre émission on
était au salon de l'agriculture
il disait attention à un débat escamoté
on écoute le président du sénat il faut
une réponse une réponse et un débat
démocratique
car on ne peut pas élire un président ou
une présidente sans un débat sur le
bilan sur le projet on ne peut pas élire
un président ou une présidente en
quelque sorte par défaut démocratique
matthews escamote on se débat
pour celui ou celle qui sera élu il y
aura un problème de légitimité et nous
sommes dans une démocratie fragile
on l'a vu avec la crise des gilet jaune
nous avons besoin que celui ou celle qui
va avoir le pays en responsabilité est
vraiment illégitimité enracinée et en
démocratie je ne connais pas autre chose
que le débat alors on entend
effectivement beaucoup ce discours chez
les opposants je sais pas mal de
d'experts ou une analyse depuis depuis
plusieurs jours mais moi je vous donnais
mon sentiment si emmanuel macron
l'emportent le 24 avril ce sera le
premier président de la cinquième
république à être réélu alors qu'il est
au pouvoir parce que françois mitterrand
c'était la cohabitation jacques chirac
c'était la cohabitation est ce que ça
suffit pas en termes de légitimité non
ça ne suffit pas on vous pensez que ça
c'est pas alors ce qui est certain c'est
que depuis en tout cas le quinquennat ce
qu'il faut regarder en termes de
légitimité c'est le score que fait le
président élu au premier tour pas au
deuxième tour et donc à chaque fois
c'est quand même moins de 30%
en tout cas là pour et mâcon ce sera
sans doute moins de 30% donc finalement
ce sera ça sa base de légitimité comme
en 2010 est donc ce qui est intéressant
de voir c'est patent l'avant élections
que la presse on parlait des sanctions
économiques les conséquences se voit
maintenant mais si la guerre dure et
s'il n'y a pas de
négociation effective avec daddy mur
poutine sur une sortie de crise les
conséquences vont être beaucoup plus dur
beaucoup plus lourde et emmanuel macron
n'aura pas la légitimité démocratique
suffisante après les élections pour
jaime silence et législatives ce cas
lorsque ses parents garantie mais le
quinquennat donne une espèce de primo au
président qui vient d'être élu au
législatif oui c'est aussi un peu le
souci avec le quinquennat comme la
cordier aucun président de la cinquième
hausse du cac depuis quinquennat n'a été
réélu pour un second mandat c'est assez
problématique et ça interroge vraiment
sur le système institutionnel mais bon
je vous entends je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord j'ai souvent pensé jérôme
sainte-marie sur la légitimité ont
brandi aussi le ring du troisième tour
social etc etc oui mais je pense que
c'est erroné je veux dire pourquoi je
suis assez d'accord avec vous en
l'espèce j'en suis désolé parce que
autant après l'élection de 2017 pour
beaucoup de français se sont dit
c'est un premier tour bizarre avec
l'intervention du parquet national
financiers contre françois fillon dont
beaucoup de gens à droite l'avait un peu
mauvaise et avec le bonne ou mauvaise
foi considérer que l'élection leur avait
été un peu voler et de fait le débat
avec elle était un peu escamoté après il
va un second tour mais qui était face à
une marine le pen qui à l'époque était
quand même très diaboliser donc c'est
est apparue comme une formalité tous les
sondages disaient que effectivement
elles seraient battus et donc beaucoup
de français encore une fois le citoyen a
droit d'être de mauvaise foi lui aussi
il est donc ce sont persuadés où étaient
persuadés que
et bien la crau n'était pas totalement
légitime et qu'en tout cas il n'avait
pas reçu le mandat des français pour
transformer radicalement la société
française comme il a essayé de me faire
durant les deux premières années d'où
d'ailleurs le caractère semi
insurrectionnelle du mouvement des gilet
jaune cette fois ci cette fois ci je
crois que c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose parce que il y aurait eu
l'élimination de jean luc mélenchon
d'eric zemmour de marine le pen via le
problème des parrainages il y aurait eu
un vrai problème de légitimité c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que du côté du
pouvoir on sait qu'à mobiliser pour
garantir que tout le monde et ses
parrainages faut trois heures
démocratique aurait entravé l'action du
gouvernement duroux du grand tout le
prochain quinquennat si ces macro keir
est lui bien entendu là cette fois ci
les français ont eu cinq ans tout de
même pour se faire une idée sur leur
président et et se faire une idée quand
même aussi sur les différends opposant
de fait le débat on le sait déjà va être
largement escamoté sur les réformes
annoncées enfin pas qui ne sont pas
annoncés lui précisément ce qu'il veut
mais qui sont déjà dans les cartons
c'est dommage mais les français ont eu
le temps de juger le maquereau ce qui se
passe là n'est pas lié cette crise elle
s'impose de l'extérieur donc je crois
que je crois que ma la fin pas
malheureusement d'ailleurs c'est heureux
mais je crois que le problème de
légitimité ne peut pas véritablement se
poser cette fois ci
je suis assez d'accord par contre sur la
sur l'après élection je pense surtout à
l'aune des discussions du jour entre
entre emmanuel macron et va nuire
poutine sur les ambitions de lumière
contient d'ukraine que la crise
l'ukrainienne est là pour durer et donc
a priori nos sanctions sont là pour
durer et on va assister de toute manière
une rééquilibrage des politiques et ce
rééquilibrage géopolitique va amener
aussi un rééquilibrage économique et
donc il est fort à parier qu'en même que
les conséquences de cet isolement
complet de la russie qui reste un
partenaire commercial important pour
l'occident et des conséquences
importantes qui vont venir
nécessairement chahuté et chambouler les
projets de réforme que emmanuel macron
entendrait si tant est qu'on les
connaisse porté dans son second volet
radicalise clairement mais en tout cas
recompositions géopolitiques va amener
une recomposition clairement des forces
en puissance et entendu des conneries il
va quand même falloir josephine staton
et là je vous rejoint d'une certaine
façon que il annonce un certain nombre
de deux pistes qui donne des
perspectives pas qu'ils se contentent
d'être le président protecteur pendant
un mois de campagne on imagine mal qu'il
n'y ait aucun programme politique aucun
projet d'ampleur que emmanuel macron
débattra dans l'est dans l'est dans les
prochaines semaines avec les autres
candidats ce serait du jamais vu en tout
cas mais j'aimerais revenir juste ce qui
a été dit moi je ne pense pas que les
français ont eu le temps de connaître
emmanuel macron pendant cinq ans ç'a été
cinq années de crise et est-ce qu'on
peut véritablement connaître un chef
d'état ses ambitions ses projets ses
réformes alors qu'il est sujet à de
multiples crises la crise des gilet
jaune qu'il a en partie causée
effectivement la crise sanitaire qui lui
est tombé dessus comme sur le reste du
monde et maintenant la crise ukrainienne
pareil qui nous tombe dessus sans qu'on
y puisse grand chose au départ donc est
ce qu'on connaît un président
lorsque son quinquennat complet est régi
par les crises c'est une question qu'il
faut poser oui moi je pense que
franchement un mois alors je suis
d'accord avec aucun de vous ça suffit
pour faire campagne mais oui ça suffit
aujourd'hui on est multi diffusés il ya
des multisupports on sait bien que le
dja sont les téléspectateurs n'est pas
braqués sur une chaîne etc on peut avoir
une information à tout instant sur nos
téléphones portables ça suffit et puis
même s'il n'y a pas de débat ça suffit
pour savoir quel est le projet
franchement les autres on les a déjà
tous que les projets dont kiel ce qui
manque que celui d'accor avec un risque
quand même series une abstention massive
si on continue d'être dans cette dans
cette petite musique qui est aussi la
nôtre d'une certaine façon de bon bah de
toute façon c'est déjà joué il a déjà
gagné il il est réélu je voudrais
terminer là dessus d'ailleurs jérôme
sainte marie on est on est sûre quel
degré d'indécision encore dans le don
dans vos dons au sondage sur voilà
est-ce que les français ceux qui savent
pour qui ils vont voter ceux qui savent
s'ils vont aller voter etc c'est très
difficile non le gredin décision n'est
pas très fort ça se cristallisent quand
même de ce cristallise on a vu naître
cette évolution jusqu'à jusqu'à la
guerre civile et jusqu'à présent ont
progressivement sa montée on s'orientait
l'emploi derrière fois faut rappeler que
ces 78 % de participation ce qui est
beaucoup en fait ce qu'il y ait une part
irréductible d'abstention là on a
orienté plutôt vers quelque chose entre
70 % de participation donc beaucoup
moins c'est un enjeu majeur pas
seulement pour des raisons symboliques
c'est aussi parce que comme ce sont les
catégories les moins politisées mais
souvent les plus populaires qui
s'abstiennent de plus ça peut vouloir
dire qu'il y aurait un effet d'auto
éviction des catégories populaires de du
débat démocratique n'aura pas forcément
des conséquences en terme de
mobilisation sociale mais disons que ça
arrivera un peu l'idée qu'on souhaite
d'autres démocraties
merci beaucoup merci à tous et est
passionnant de participer à ce débat